you know there are little things that
can happen sometimes which though
seemingly insignificant on their own
still so perfectly exemplify a larger
issue that they're worth more attention
than we might otherwise tend to afford
them that i think is the case with this
recent tweet from the aclu now as you
may know there was a time many moons ago
when the american civil liberties union
concerned itself with defending civil
liberties it was once so committed to
the first amendment that it defended the
speech and assembly rights of the kkk
and nazis that's when it took the c and
l part of the name seriously but those
days have been over for a long time now
the c l may as well stand for
you know communist lunatics or crazy
leftists or whatever you want to put in
there
they are nothing but a group of far left
agitators at this point often
positioning them positioning themselves
further out on the leftist fringe
than even the most fringe leftists have
and that brings us to the tweet posted
in honor of the anniversary
of uh rbg's death a few days ago
in the caption they write with justice
ruth bader ginsburg's death we lost a
champion for abortion and gender
equality and on the anniversary of her
death the fight to protect abortion
access is more urgent than ever
so far so normal
but then in an image below the caption
they included a quote from rbg herself
the original quote the one that their
version is based on
says uh this is quoting rbg now
the decision whether or not to bear a
child is central to a woman's life to
her well-being and dignity when
government controls the decision for her
she is being treated as less than a
fully adult human responsible for her
own choices again pretty normal
we're leaving aside for now the problems
with the original quote itself of course
a a woman
makes the decision to potentially bear a
child when she engages in the sexual act
um the sexual act is the reproductive
act so even if you don't intend to
reproduce you're still engaging in the
reproductive act which can have that
consequence and has had that consequence
literally billions of times in human
history once conception occurs whether
she intended it or not she she is now
bearing a child she cannot preserve her
dignity by going to the abortionist and
paying hundreds of dollars to have that
baby killed and in fact by expecting a
mother to care for her children rather
than murder them we are indeed treating
her like a fully adult human
that's what we expect adults to do
you treat a woman as less than an adult
and even less than human
when you propose that she may need to
murder her own kids for the sake of her
own well-being
the point is there are many problems
with the quote from rbg
but the quote is the quote i mean she
said what she said i could disagree with
what she said
but i can't change the fact that she
said it
on that point the aclu begs to differ
in their version of the quote posted to
twitter in honor of rbg and to
commemorate the anniversary of her death
the organization gives us this this is
the quote that they
have the decision whether or not to bear
a child is central to a person's life to
their well-being and dignity when the
government controls that decision for
people
they are being treated as less than a
fully adult human responsible for their
own choices
yes the aclu removed the word woman
from
ruth bader ginsburg's quote about women
now it's
it's hard to know where to begin in
surveying all the problems with a move
like this
so let's just start with a basic point
about quotes
namely
that this is not how quotes work
you cannot alter the words in a quote to
change the meaning or update the content
the aclu takes woman and her and they
take that out and they sub in people and
they and they put that in brackets
okay but you you don't get away with it
by putting in brackets because that's
not how brackets work either
brackets are used to clarify someone's
meaning or to add necessary details for
example if i were to say
just as an example
lamar jackson is a better play maker
than patrick mahomes
you could repeat that quote accurately
and validly by saying matt walsh said
quote
brackets baltimore ravens quarterback
lamar jackson is a better playmaker than
bracket's kansas city chiefs quarterback
patrick mahomes that would clarify my
meaning and provide necessary
information to people who may not be
familiar with the names that i used
you're adding words in
but in a clarifying way
but if you objected to the content of my
statement it would not be valid to say
matt walsh said quote lamar jackson is
brackets not a better play maker than
patrick holmes that may be what you
think i ought to have said but it's not
what i said
so it would not be true to say that i
said it
that's english 101 i guess english 101
lesson if we can move past that
the greater point is that the aclu has
just perfectly demonstrated how
left-wing gender theory totally
undermines and negates the feminist
argument for women's rights
after all you can't have women's rights
if you don't have women
the irony is that is that in their
caption of the altered quote they credit
rbg with advancing gender equality and
then they proceed in the very next step
to erase gender entirely
just imagine for a second
how every standard feminist talking
point will sound once you once you sub
the words people or person for women or
woman
this is actually kind of fun it's a fun
game you can play on your own
i'll get you started for example
here's a claim you've heard a million
times
women earn 80 earn 82 cents for every
dollar men earn
now that's not at all true but that's
not the point
let's consider the claim again
with the aclu's edits
people earn 82 cents for every dollar
people earn
suddenly a political talking point that
was coherent yet false
becomes incoherent redundant and still
false
or try another statement that you've
heard many times you know you've heard
something to this effect many times
we must defeat male privilege so that
men and women are finally equal
that now becomes we must defeat people
privilege so that people and people are
finally equal
and so on as i said every feminist
talking point every single one is
reduced to ash and rubble by this change
in fact just last night nikki fryed
who's uh that silly woman down in
florida is running for governor
she tweeted simply elect women
like i said a silly person
uh but this now becomes as dumb as that
is well just elect women yeah just elect
women
but now that becomes elect people
and i mean that at least makes some kind
of sense i guess hopefully we all agree
that we should be electing people and
not say snakes and rodents
though congress would seem to suggest
that we don't all agree on that point
either way it's impossible to advocate
for electing women
if there is apparently no such thing
now
another point i think has to be made
here
many people on the right when they see
this sort of thing play out
they're inclined to sit back grab a
popcorn and a soda and watch the left
eat itself
the belief the hope the quite fanciful
hope i think
is that the left will self-destruct
under the weight of its own
contradictions
many of us expect that there will be
some sort of war of attrition between
the conflicting factions and in the end
they'll all be destroyed right
the trans activists who wish to erase
women
the feminists who wishes to elevate
women above men both of these sides
cannot co-exist much less achieve any
kind of mutual victory we think
so let them fight and and and we will
win by default
this is the attitude of many on the
right
and i understand it i understand that
attitude
it's an optimistic attitude
it's wrong for two reasons first
this assumes that the left notices these
contradictions and is bothered by them
it assumes that they feel the need to be
consistent or coherent they don't
one of the marks of a tyrant one of the
things that makes them a tyrant
and modern american leftism is a
tyrannical movement
one of the marks of a tyrant is that he
is arbitrary and inconsistent and you
are expected to cooperate with and
affirm his whims in any given moment
this is a feature not a bug it's part of
the point
especially for relativists who deny that
there is any sort of objective or
knowable truth the truth changes on a
dime sometimes from one sentence to the
next which is how the aclu celebrates
gender equality in one sentence and in
the very next sentence denies the
existence of gender
this is all a part of the tyrannical
relativist game
second
thing
um and this is where it gets even more
depressing
if there is a conflict between what we
might call traditional left-wing
feminists
you know they're so old-fashioned and
traditional that they believe that you
know only women have uteruses but if
there's a conflict between them
and the trans agenda
and if it's true that either side must
achieve a zero-sum victory
then the trans agenda will triumph
arguably they already have
they hold all of the cultural power
right now and have already used it to
enact sweeping catastrophic previously
unimaginable changes
and they've been able to do this in an
incredibly short amount of time
they have they have totally altered
the way that even average
people on the street
view biological sex
um
the you know the philosopher i think was
charles taylor has this concept called
the social imaginary
and that that has to do with
the way you know you have you have the
the academics with their theories
and average people on the street
who really aren't aware of those
theories and aren't participating in
those in those conversations in the
ivory towers well the social imaginary
is when those theories filter their way
down into society
and becomes part of the sort of
intuitive
sense that it becomes this intuitive
sense that everybody shares
when people in society start believing
something seemingly intuitively without
even knowing why they believe it
and so these ideas about gender from
from from the uh from the left they
become part of the social imaginary
average people buy into this stuff
without knowing why they buy into it
without knowing where it comes from
without being able to explain it
but the point is that the trans
activists have been able to inject this
stuff into the social imaginary
to to craft and mold the social
imaginary in a very short amount of time
what does that mean it means that
they're going to win that fight with the
feminists and though it may be briefly
satisfying to watch all of those
feminist medusas suffer such a
humiliating fate and i don't deny that
it is
satisfying to watch
the reality is that the victors will be
significantly worse
in fact it's not so much that feminists
would be supplanted by trans advocates
but that they would be passing the baton
even if unwillingly
it would represent a transition much
like you know stage three cancer
transitions to stage four
the great project of left-wing feminism
was to undermine and destroy
at least in the societal consciousness
moral truth
and certain biological truths
as we move to stage four
and our cultural cancer becomes terminal
the modern gender warriors take us from
the rejection of moral truth and certain
biological truths
to the rejection of truth itself
and biology itself
that is the shift
that we are all now witnessing
it suddenly becomes
not quite as funny when you look at it
like that if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends